YES, WE BEGIN WITH BREAKING
NEWS.
THIS IS DON LEMON, TONIGHT WITH
BREAKING NEWS OUT OF CHICAGO.
THE CHICAGO TEACHERS UNION,
VOTING TO ACCEPT A DEAL TO
REOPEN CITY SCHOOLS.
LET'S LISTEN TO A PRESS
CONFERENCE THE MAYOR, LAURIE
LIGHTFOOT, IS SPEAKING.
>> ANOTHER THING THAT HAS BEEN
DONE OVER THESE DIFFICULT FEW
DAYS, IS TO ENSURE THAT THEIR
VOICES WERE HEARD.
I ENCOURAGE, YOU KEEP GOING.
WE NEED YOU AT THE TABLE,
ALWAYS.
SOME WILL ASK, WHO, ONE WHO
LOST?
NO ONE WINS WHEN OUR STUDENTS
ARE OUT OF THE PLACE WHERE THEY
CAN LEARN BEST, AND WHERE THEY
ARE SAFEST.
AFTER BEING OUT OF SCHOOL FOR 4
DAYS IN A ROW, I'M SURE MANY
STUDENTS WILL BE EXCITED TO GET
BACK INTO THE CLASSROOM, WITH
THEIR TEACHERS, AND PEERS, AND
PARENTS, AND GUARDIANS, SO THEY
CAN NOW BREATHE A MUCH DESERVED
SIGH OF RELIEF.
I KNOW THERE ARE HARDSHIPS THAT
PEOPLE ENDURE THROUGH THIS
PROCESS.
WE HAVE TO MAKE SURE, WE ARE
UNDERSTANDING THAT, AND DOING
EVERYTHING WE COULD TO SUPPORT
YOU, TO GET OVER THESE
DIFFICULT DAYS.
THIS MOST RECENT FIGHT, IF YOU
WANT TO CALL IT THAT, IT IS A
FIGHT TO ACCESS FOR IN-PERSON
LEARNING.
LEARNING, THAT IS FAR SUPERIOR
TO THE REMOTE PROGRAMMING OUR
STUDENTS HAD TO ENDURE, FOR FAR
TOO, LONG LAST YEAR.
LET ME REMIND YOU, WHEN WE WERE
ALL REMOTE BEFORE, WE LOST
CONTACT WITH 100,000 CHILDREN.
THAT IS NEARLY ONE 3RD OF RCEP
HAS SCHOOL POPULATION.
A 3RD.
WE'RE GOING THROUGH PARENTS, OR
GUARDIANS, WHO LOST THEIR JOBS,
BECAUSE WE'RE HAVING TO MONITOR
THEIR CHILDREN AT HOME.
NO PARENT SHOULD BE FORCED TO
MAKE THE CHOICE BETWEEN EARNING
AN INCOME, TO TAKE CARE OF
THEIR FAMILY, OR BEING HOME, TO
MONITOR THEIR KIDS ON REMOTE
LEARNING.
THAT'S A SITUATION WE SHOULD
NEVER FORCE PARENTS INTO.
ABSENT AN EMERGENCY, THAT DID
NOT MANIFEST ITSELF, THIS TIME.
THINK ABOUT WHO OUR KIDS ARE.
70% OF OUR KIDS, QUALIFYING FOR
FREE, AND REDUCE LUNCH.
MEANING, THEY COME FROM POOR,
AND WORKING CLASS FAMILIES.
FAMILIES WITH ADULTS, WHO,
SOMETIMES, WORK MULTIPLE JOBS,
TO KEEP THE FAMILY AFLOAT.
SWITCHING, COMPLETELY, BACK TO
REMOTE LEARNING WITHOUT A
PUBLIC HEALTH REASON TO DO SO.
IT WOULD HAVE CREATED, AND
AMPLIFIED, THE SOCIAL,
EMOTIONAL, AND ECONOMIC TURMOIL,
THAT FAR TOO MANY OF OUR
FAMILIES ARE FACING.
WE CAN NEVER FORGET THE IMPACT
ON THE LIVES OF OUR CHILDREN,
AND THEIR FAMILIES.
THEY, MUST ALWAYS, BE FRONT AND
CENTER.
EVERY DECISION MUST BE MADE
WITH THEM AT THE FOREFRONT.
THERE ARE MANY PEOPLE TO THANKS
FOR GETTING US TO THIS MOMENT.
I WANT TO THANK, FIRST AND
FOREMOST, SEE PCO MARTINEZ.
THEY HAVE DONE HUMANS WORK, AND
HAVE BEEN STEADFAST PARTNERS
AND MAKING SURE THAT WE FOCUS
ON GETTING OUR CHILDREN BACK TO
IN-PERSON LEARNING.
THANKS ALSO TO SEE THE PH
COMMISSIONER, ALISON, AND HER
TEAM, WHO PROVIDE THE SCIENCE,
IN THE DATA, TO ENSURE WE WERE
MAKING INFORMED DECISIONS, THAT
RECOGNIZE, OF COURSE, THE SURGE
IN OMICRON, BUT DIDN'T ABANDON
THE SCIENCE IN THE MIDST OF A
PANDEMIC, AND A LOT OF
MISINFORMATION THAT WAS BEING
SPREAD.
SO, THANK YOU, DOCTOR.
I WOULD ALSO LIKE TO THINK
THOSE IN THE SCHOOL COMMUNITY,
NOT FOR DESTROYING THEIR
PATIENTS, BUT MAKING THEIR
VOICE HEARD THROUGHOUT THIS
PROCESS.
I CAN'T THINK THE PARENTS
ENOUGH.
THANK YOU.
THANK YOU FOR BEING STEADFAST.
THANK YOU FOR BEING RESOLUTE.
THANK YOU FOR BEING RELENTLESS.
AND, LAST, BUT NOT LEAST --
>> CHICAGO MAYOR, LAURIE
LIGHTFOOT, HOLDING A PRESS
CONFERENCE.
THE CHICAGO TEACHERS UNION,
ACCEPTING A DEAL TO REOPEN THE
CITY SCHOOLS, SOME 340,000
CHILDREN HAVE BEEN OUT OF
CLASSES SINCE WEDNESDAY OF LAST
WEEK.
TOMORROW, THEY WILL BE IN
CLASS.
THE MAYOR, EXPLAINING WHAT IS
HAPPENING THERE.
ALSO, THANKING THE CHICAGO
PUBLIC HEALTH COMMISSIONER, WHO
WE HAD ON LAST WEEK.
DR. ALLISON ARWADY, FOR HER
HELP IN THIS SITUATION.
MUCH TO THE RELIEF, I'M SURE,
OF MANY PARENTS, AND FOLKS IN
CHICAGO.
THE SCHOOLS WILL BE OPEN,
TOMORROW.
MORE THAN 350,000 STUDENTS WILL
BE BACK IN CLASS, PUBLIC SCHOOL
STUDENTS.
WE GO TO CNN'S OMAR JIMENEZ,
WHO'S BEEN COVERING THE STORY
IN CHICAGO.
OMAR, THE TEACHERS UNION,
TONIGHT, VOTING TO ACCEPT THAT
DEAL.
WHAT ELSE DO YOU KNOW?
DETAILS IF YOU HAVE, THEM
PLEASE.
>> IT'S ALL PRELIMINARY, RIGHT
NOW, DON.
THEY VOTED TO ACCEPT THIS DEAL,
THERE WERE A HOUSE OF DELEGATES,
AND THEY VOTED TO SUSPEND THEIR
PUSH FOR REMOTE WORK ACTION,
WHICH, OF COURSE, LED TO THESE
CANCELLATIONS FROM THE DISTRICT
SIDE.
THE DETAILS WE HAVE GOTTEN SO
FAR, IS THAT TOMORROW, IT WILL
BE TEACHERS WHO COME BACK FIRST
IN-PERSON, AND THEN, ON
WEDNESDAY, STUDENTS WILL THEN
COME BACK AFTER.
IT DOESN'T BRING BACK STUDENTS
RIGHT AWAY, AS WE JUST HEARD ON
THE DETAILS THAT WE JUST HEARD.
WE JUST GOT A FEW MOMENTS AGO.
ONE OF THE MORE INTERESTING
PARTS THAT WILL BE SIGNIFICANT
IS WHAT GOT THEM OVER THE EDGE
HERE.
PRIOR TO TONIGHT, IT IS TESTING,
WHICH IS THE TEACHERS UNIT
WANTING UNIVERSAL, WHAT THEY,
CALLED OPT OUT TESTING.
SO, EVERYONE WAS TESTED NO
MATTER WHAT, BUT THE CITY SAID,
WE WANT TO OPT IN TESTING.
THAT WAY, WE CAN GET PARENTAL
CONSENT FOR THE STUDENTS TO BE
TESTED.
THEY ALSO WANT TO, BASICALLY,
TO STAY REMOTE UNTIL JANUARY
18TH.
THE CITY SAID, NO, WE WON'T DO,
REMOTES TOO DETRIMENTAL TO
EDUCATION.
PLUS, DATA SHOWS, BEING IN
PERSON IS SAFE.
IT WILL BE INTERESTING TO SEE
WHAT DETAILS, EVENTUALLY, GOT
THEM OVER THE EDGE, AND DURING
THIS EVENING THE CEO, PEDRO
MARTINEZ, HAS SAID THAT THEY
WERE CAUTIOUSLY OPTIMISTIC AND
IT IS IN HIS RECENT DAYS, TODAY,
TO HAVE ACTUALLY PLAYED OUT.
>> I'M GLAD TO HAVE THE DETAILS,
AND THEY HAVE CASE BACK
TOMORROW, AND THEY WON'T BE
BACK TOMORROW.
IT WILL BE 5 DAYS SINCE
NEGOTIATIONS HAVE BEEN GOING ON
FOR DAYS NOW.
TODAY, THE FIRST DAY THAT THEY
WERE OUT OF THE CLASSROOM.
IT'S BEEN 5 DAYS.
A LEGIT WEEK THAT THESE KIDS
ARE OUT OF SCHOOL.
WHAT IS GOING ON WITH THE
NEGOTIATIONS?
>> THIS BEGAN, AND THE VOTE WAS
INSPIRED, AND THE BOTTOM LINE,
FEEL THAT THE SCHOOL DISTRICT
DID NOT PROVIDE ADEQUATE ENOUGH
SCHOOL DISTRICTS TO COME BACK
TO THE CLASSROOM SAFELY.
THEY FELT THAT THINGS WERE
LACKING AND CATEGORIES LIKE
CONTACT TRACING, BEING ABLE TO
PROVIDE QUALITY MASK FOR PEOPLE,
AND I MENTIONED THE TESTING
ASPECT BEFORE, AS WELL AS
RECORD LEVELS OF COVID-19.
AMONG STUDENTS, STAFF, AND
SURROUNDING CHICAGO COMMUNITY,
AND RECENT WEEKS.
THAT IS WHAT IS GOING TO BE END
THE STANDOFF, IF YOU WANT TO DO
THAT.
CHICAGO PUBLIC SCHOOLS, WHO
CANCELED, CLASS SAID WE CAN'T
SEND CHILDREN TO KNOW IF OUR
TEACHERS ARE, ACTUALLY, GOING
TO BE THERE.
THEY THEN BEGAN TO WHITTLE AWAY,
AND THAT'S WHY I THINK THAT IF
WE SEE THESE DETAILS OF WHAT'S
BROUGHT THEM OVER THE FINISH
LINE, BECAUSE ANOTHER ASPECT OF
THE TESTING THAT THEY WANTED,
IS THEY WANTED EVERYONE, WHO
NEEDED THEM, TO HAVE ACCESS TO
AT HOME TESTS.
THE HOLDUP THERE, IS A DISTRICT
SAID, WE DON'T HAVE ENOUGH
TESTS TO GUARANTEE THAT.
IT WILL BE INTERESTING TO SEE
IF THEY GOT MORE TESTS FROM
ELSEWHERE, AND THEY'RE COMING
OUT NOW HERE ON MONDAY.
>> DR. ALLISON ARWADY ON LAST
WEEK, SHE SAID, SHE BELIEVED,
THAT KIDS WERE SAFER IN SCHOOL,
HEALTH WISE, BECAUSE THEY MAY
NOT BE DISTANCING AT HOME.
THAT MANY STUDENTS ONLY MEALS,
OR MOST OF THE FOOD THAT THEY
GET WHERE THEY COME FROM, OUR
SCHOOLS.
SCHOOLS WOULD'VE BEEN BETTER
OFF IN SCHOOL, EVEN WITH THE
PANDEMIC.
IT IS A HUGE INCONVENIENCE FOR
IT.
WOULD HAVE BEEN HEARING FROM
THE COMMUNITY THERE?
>> THE BOTTOM LINE, OR THE
QUESTION THAT THE SCHOOL
DISTRICT PARENTS, AND OTHERS
WERE HAVING, IS WHAT IS WORSE.
IT IS REMOTE LEARNING, AND
PUTTING A DETRIMENT AND IT WAS
STAYING REMOTE, AND IT WAS
HEALTH POTENTIALLY.
THESE PARENTS, AND TEACHERS,
ARE FACING.
PARENTS AND I SPOKE TO ABOUT
THIS OR FRUSTRATED.
IT WAS BOTH SIDES, AND BEING
ABLE TO CONSISTENCY.
IT IS A 2ND YEAR IN A ROW, AND
THEN LED TO A CONSOLATION, AND
THE CHICAGO SCHOOL DISTRICTS,
BECAUSE OF COVID.
I THINK PARENTS HERE, JUST
WANTED TO FIND OUT HOW THEY
WERE GOING TO CONTINUE THIS
EDUCATION FOR THIS.
IT IS COMING AT THIS LATE HOUR,
AND ONE SE